[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
hey guys going into episode 5 the last
war for the Iron Throne everyone wonders
what will happen to Danny in Shogun what
will happen to Jonny Tyrion is then he
going to burn down King's Landing and
will we finally see more brains powers
how every search they're going to die is
not one of those questions and one can
see why every main character wants to
kill her and there's no way search that
gets out of this one alive and I agree
search his reign is over and she will
die because remember when you play Game
of Thrones you win or you die
there's no middle ground I think we all
can agree on Cersei losing the bed well
King's Landing and it's very ever going
to talk about who is most likely going
to kill Cersei in the upcoming episode
we have many candidates from Danian
jørgen burning her inside red cape to
our end account sneaking up inside
killing the mountain and then Cersei as
well there's also Jaime Lannister who at
the end of an episode forest riding
south to King's Landing let's start with
Jaime
he made a tough decision in the last
episode the last of the Starks but it's
the one that could mean huge things for
the fate of Westeros Game of Thrones
wants us to think he might be changing
sides back to team Cersei in season 8
episode 5 but it seems far more likely
that he'll give up his own life trying
to kill her
episode 4 included a huge victory party
at Winterfell
after they burned the dead with Jaime
and Brienne finally consummating the
Romans they built up over the years
later when Danny and John ride off to
war with several other major characters
and torment heads back north of the wall
with Wildings brain decided to stay at
Winterfell to protect Sansa Jaime stays
with her and for a minute it seemed like
this might be their happily ever after
but after the news breaks of young
graduates attack on Dan his fleet
leading to death or a girl I miss a nice
capture senses words cut Jaime the most
I always wanted to be there when they
execute your sisters and success seems
like I won't get a chance in the middle
of the night Jamie packs up to leave
Brienne plead with him to stay is saying
that he's a good man and so much better
than Cersei you can't save her Brienne
says you don't need to die with her stay
here stay with me please
Brienne as well as all of us are led to
believe that Jaime switching sides back
to team Cersei fleeing back to his
landing to protect his sister informal
lover
by James responds makes him sound like a
man who still feels like he hasn't
redeemed himself in
when talking to Bri and Jamie recounts
his terrible deeds pushing bran out the
window strangling his cousin whilst in
prison by Robb Stark in retaking river
on four natales in season six he did all
of this for Cersei
she's hateful and so am i Jaime says his
self-loathing is not necessarily an
admission of guilt so much as it's his
motive for going to kill Cersei it's an
action that will break his heart
Jaime's the kind of aunt hero who's okay
with doing a despicable act if it serves
the greater good something he writes for
King's Landing he's probably going to
kill another monarch rather than a die
beside Cersei in the upcoming battle
it's also telling that Jamie doesn't
bring up killing the Mad King Aerys saw
his list of hateful deeds the act that
turned him the Kingslayer nickname -
Jaime killing the Mad King is the only
noble action he did Jaime will always
love Cersei on some level and killing
her will be even more difficult for him
than killing King Aerys but just like
then he's recognized he has it within
his power to end war and prevent a lot
of suffering prevent a lot of innocent
people from dying it is come true it
would also fulfill the bellacor prophecy
that Cersei will die at the hands of a
younger brother look closely this shot
from the season 7 premiere that might
have a shadow Jamie being the valonqar
that will put an end to Cersei above
cercis head the words the neck just
above Jaime the fingers well Jamie wrap
his fingers around his neck perhaps from
the episode 5 trailer we know for a fact
that Jaime will sneak inside King's
Landing as here you can see him a hooded
man passing to the golden company as
they march out to King's Landing to face
the upcoming Danish forces is the same
cloak and hood he had been arriving him
in a film while the golden company
marches outside King's Landing Jamie's
heading towards the red key to face his
sister Cersei I believe serves avail
much like the Mad King did want to use
wildfire to burn the moment she comes to
realization she's lost the war perhaps
after the golden company betrays her and
sides we take a Targaryen after a nurse
fleet burns senator older scorpions are
destroyed after the small folk is safely
escorted out to the Red Keep and when
she sees Danny riding shotgun to burn
her in her castle
Cersei might give an order to Qyburn to
burn them all to burn the entire King's
Landing with one fire I mean that's most
definitely what's her savato after she
sees she's lost the war if she cannot
live then normal however search they
will not manage to pull up this place
the valonqar bill stopper the valonqar
being the one who already prevented such
plan from happening during Robert's
rebellion Jamie Lannister will sub
Cersei from burning down the entire
capital and its population to the ground
Jaime will kill the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms once again but this time people
will not mock his name Jaime will be
remembered as a hero and his great deed
will fulfill his empty pages in the
famous book of brothers Brienne will
make sure all Jaime's deeds are written
down this would in my opinion be the
best possible way to execute the
valonqar prophecy and the end of the
Lannister twins the man queen and Jaime
Lannister
I believe Jaime will be the one to kill
his sister and once again save King's
Landing Jaime Laurita sacrificed his
honor once in order to save hundreds of
thousands of innocent lives by killing
the Mad King and has ever since been
called the Kingslayer however Cersei now
intends to do the same it's pretty safe
to say Jamie's going to kill his sister
once she gives an order to Qyburn - as
the Mad King used to say burn them all
thereby truly earning the reputation of
the King's lair or in this case Queens
lair all its life it's been an insult
but now people will call in that in
triumph Jaime will do noble sacrifice
once again by killing the mad monarch
but it's time he will not trade it with
his honor this time it requires his life
Jaime will sacrifice himself by killing
star says he knows the mountain will
kill him immediately that's one
possibility the other is are you killing
Cersei Arya start the hero of nfl's
celebrated making the most important
kill by practicing her archery skills
while everyone else engaged in more
old-fashioned feast but is innate
episode 4 also set arya down a path that
could lead to her completing that
infamous kill list before the series
ends here's why Arya could very easily
be the one to kill Cersei Lannister in
episodes five or six well everyone else
team NFL celebrated their victory over
the night king the hound and Arya Stark
were two of the only people who could
not seem to enjoy themselves not long
after the victory party the Hound left
Winterfell and Arya was there to follow
him they both mentioned having an
unfinished business at King's Landing
and neither one of them had any plan to
come back what are they really talking
about here it's almost only a joint
suicide mission to infiltrate King's
Landing and kill the mountain and Cersei
Lannister
they're really nice traveling companions
also echoes back to their time together
in seasons three and four Emmit Arya
skills to the faceless assassin
we're starting the thing they might
actually pull this off the counts
unfinished business definitely refers to
his lifelong grudge against his older
sibling the mountain was currently some
kind of a zombie slave to Cersei the
gamble is a popular fan theory pitting
these two brothers together in a battle
to death which has always been pretty
essential anyone who wants to kill
Cersei will have to first take down the
mountain and the Hound is probably one
of the only warriors big enough to stand
a chance in the season finale they found
in the mountain encountered one neither
the dragon pit meeting remember me the
hound Estes brother
yeah you do what did they do to you
doesn't matter that's not how it ends
for you brother you know who's coming
for you you've always known the Hound
fighting the mountain feels inevitable
all in the service of artists are
killing Cersei Lannister
when Arya was imprisoned at Harrenhal
years ago she added the mountain to her
killest because he tortured and killed
people she cared about so it's possible
that Arya would not mind fighting
alongside account for Coe gamble
her main target however is definitely
Cersei Lannister we also have not seen
reflects her faceless magic in season
eight so she'll probably very someone
else's face to get close to Cersei some
fans theorize she'll wear Jaime
Lannister's face to do the deed which
would technically fulfill the valonqar
prophecy because Ariane the hound left
workings Landing before Jon Danny and
Jaime they're probably already within
the city gates by the time is team is
saying they'd be headed that the episode
sent Cersei also mentioned during
episode four they left the gates open to
flood the city with innocent people
this might prevent Danny from attacking
directly with her one remaining rag on
but it also makes Sara more vulnerable
to sneaky assassins the last option is
Danny killing starts david ragan fire
inside castle
at the end of episode four Dan is left
with one and only choice Daanish fire
and blood and Cersei literally Danny's
vision of King's Landing actually
contain a huge spoiler for Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 5 back in
season two Danny had a vision that she
was in the iron throne room but
everything was destroyed and the ground
was covered in snow or so he thought now
that the night king is dead and then is
seemingly ready to burn King's Landing
to the ground the snow in Danny's vision
was actually an ash the throne room
covered in ash makes a lot more sense at
this point in season eight it also seems
to suggest that despite the best efforts
of her advisers tyranny marries Danny
will follow mustiness final words
cars and burn everything and everyone in
Rea then again maybe then is not one who
ends up burning is leaning to the ground
after all she is not the only one
capable of blowing up the castle
Cersei still has wild fire under the Red
Keep and she could use it to destroy the
Iron Throne rather than see her enemy
take it either way it seems pretty clear
that King's Landing will be largely
destroyed and covered with ash by the
end of Game of Thrones season 8 in
conclusion I believe Jaime will be the
one to kill Cersei or upon the mountain
will kill him after Jaime kill sir send
the mountain kills Jaime the gamble will
probably take place as I believe that
the moment Arya and the Hound will
arrive Arya and the Hound will then
together kill the mountain but he'll
most likely get mortally injured in
process and are able probably have to
give her old friend a gift of death out
of mercy however Danny doesn't know all
of this happened for all she knows Circe
is still studying on the Iron Throne
and then she will has leaked photos
confirmed burned down the red keep let's
hope Arya escapes on time if you'd like
to hear more leaks and information we
have about episode 5 make sure to watch
our previous title video season 8
episode 5 preview and leak scenes who do
you think will put an end to Cersei
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace